you look good you do look good I know
you do look amazing amazing well let's
not get crazy you did see me naked I
finally don't look like I'm wearing a
belt when I get naked like really yeah
like my body just goes down those the
bulbs out oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I lost
like 35 pounds good for you 35 pounds
this is the result of a ritual that you
started a while ago you and some friends
that's called sober October and I've
heard about this cuz you and a bunch of
buddies decided to do this what's
entailed with sober October is it just
not drinking oh no no it's me Joe Rogan
Tom Segura
Ari Shaffir I guess you could say they
had like what we'd call a soft
intervention for me mm-hmm they asked me
how much I drank one time on a podcast
and I was I was honest like an idiot I
was like nine drinks and then some girl
lost it and he's like those are doubles
I was like yeah about 18 drinks a night
Oh a night you men a week no no that was
a night shout-out to Tito's and um and
so they said you could you think you
could quit drinking for 30 days I was
like easy-peasy so we did this no drugs
no alcohol and we did 15 hot yoga's and
then we've changed the physical
challenge but we just didn't drink or do
drugs which is funny to hear my
daughter's tell people to be like Burt
you want a drink and my daughter was
like nah he's not using drugs are out
all this month he's doing yoga yeah but
this one this this sober October we just
got done we're wearing these whoop
straps and we did 10 lessons of anything
we wanted to do so I took surfing
lessons spearfishing lessons tactical
gun training I was one of the funnest
segura learned how to fly a plane wait
how does that burn calories oh oh no
it's about better about losing weight
yeah if you just [ __ ] yourself the whole
time no and then I did I did hot spin
every single day I did hot spin so it
was it was I loved sober October I don't
know why I don't quit drinking why I
know why I don't listen don't mean to
say all out
know exactly what you're doing you learn
to dance for this and you hired a
hip-hop dance instructor is that what I
pitched these guys we have a challenge
every year I said I want to do I want to
do hip hop dance my daughters and I are
obsessed on Instagram with hip hop dance
videos and dr. pimple popper and so we
we text back and forth to each other
non-stop and so I've hired this girl
Delaney Glaser and she taught me how to
dance and I did a dance and I posted
online going this is what we should do
for this October right and I would say
it's the greatest thing I've ever done
all right
[Music]
here's it's crazy you know so here
here's what's interesting what's even
crazier is that someone at America's Got
Talent
saw that video did not know that you're
a comedian screwing around and called to
book you on the show
correct they email me they're like you
see yourself more as a comedian or a
dancer they had to willfully not do any
research less than no reason to actually
go I don't want to see anymore are you a
comedian or a dancer I had tour dates
for my body shots to tour all scrolling
down the side and then I was like and
then I posted it on Instagram and they
got really upset wait big America's Got
Talent got upset the casting director
I'm so sorry lady that if you're
watching this but yeah she was like hey
she called my agent she's like you need
to have him take that down and like
that's definitely not gonna happen yeah
I wish I so badly wanted to go out for a
mirror only thing I wanted more than
that was I would love for post Malone to
have watched that video tweeted it and
then been like me and you need to party
and grow I could drink that guy under a
table and a harpy